TONY PUJALS: You've
probably heard
about Anthos, Google
Cloud's application
platform for modern
enterprise environments.
If you want a chance to
try Anthos for yourself,
the good news is now you can.
I'm going to show
you exactly how easy
it is to get started exploring
Anthos using the Anthos sample
deployment.
When we're done, go
ahead and follow the link
to our online tutorial, launch
your own sample deployment,
and try out Anthos for yourself.
We have a sample application--
an online store--
that's an example of a modern
microservices application that
will run in the multi-cluster
Kubernetes environment created
by our deployment.
Everything I show
you and more is
published as a tutorial
in our online docs.
This is where you want
to go to get started.
What I'm going to show you will
be running in Google Cloud,
but keep in mind
that Anthos is here
to help you build and manage
your modern application
workloads running where
your enterprise needs them,
whether that's on Google
Cloud, multi-cloud,
or in hybrid environments.
This sample deployment
is two clusters
for hosting copies of
our application services.
There's also a config
repo that we'll
use for maintaining all
configuration under version
control.
We'll access Cloud Shell from
a browser to edit policies
in a clone of the config repo.
We'll push committed changes
to the upstream config repo
and then they will get
automatically synchronized
across both clusters by
Anthos Config Management.
Let's dive right in.
We need a project for the
services and resources
that the Anthos sample
deployment will use or create.
For this tour, we'll
start with a new one.
And then let's navigate
to the Anthos Dashboard.
We'll need to enable
the Anthos API.
And then again, back
at the dashboard,
we can now launch
the deployment.
You can click through.
Accept any defaults.
After around 10
minutes, everything
will be deployed,
configured, and running.
After the deployment
is finished,
let's go back to
the Anthos Dashboard
to explore the infrastructure
resources that were created.
From here, we can
see overall health.
We can go ahead and
inspect our clusters
and drill down into
individual clusters.
And then head over
to Kubernetes Engine,
where we can see more details.
Drilling down into
physical nodes,
where we can see the Pods
that are scheduled on them
or take a look at the
actual workloads, where
we can see everything
running across all nodes
and namespaces, or a
specific namespace,
like the one for
the application.
Now, let's take a look
at the web front-end.
Services & Ingress show us
a list of all the services
with network endpoints.
Let's filter on
istio-ingressgateway,
which is the name of
the services hosting
the endpoints for our
application's front-end.
Click on one of these for
either of our clusters.
Ingress manages inbound
traffic to our application,
and we can see what that looks
like by clicking on the exposed
endpoint.
Looks like the
application is working.
Let's switch view now.
This web application is made
up of a number of communicating
microservices, so
let's see how things
look from the internal traffic
perspective of Anthos Service
Mesh.
Back at the Anthos Dashboard,
let's inspect services
managed by the service mesh.
We've got two views
available-- the default table
view and a topology view.
These views provide a
great deal of information
without having to write
any custom monitoring
code whatsoever.
The table view presents us
with essential service metrics
like error rate and
percentile latency,
while the topology
view presents us
with a graph visualization of
our workloads and services.
From either view, we
have a way to drill down
into a detail page
for any service,
as we can see here, using
the shippingservice.
In this service detail view,
we can see telemetry details
that provide an overview of the
shippingservice's performance.
If we use the left nav and
click Connected Services,
we can see inbound and
outbound connections
for our shippingservice.
We can even note that traffic
over these connections
is unencrypted by looking
at the lock icons.
From these pages we're able to
inspect service mesh details,
but what happens when
there's an issue?
Let's check out the monitoring
built into Anthos Service Mesh.
At the table view,
we can see a summary
at the top of the services we're
monitoring with a service level
objective or SLO.
Right now, it
looks like none are
being monitored for
performance, so let's fix that.
We'll click into the
shoppingcartservice
to create an SLO using latency
as our indicator performance
and choosing a
very low threshold,
like five milliseconds with
a goal of 90% compliance
over a one-day rolling period.
This will let us see
an example of what
it looks like when we have
service performance that
exceeds our daily error budget.
After we submit this
SLO, we can easily
see it in the Health panel.
Let's go back to
our Services table.
We can see that we've
now upgraded to have
only 10 services without SLOs.
For the shippingcartservice
with an SLO,
we can see that our
intentionally aggressive
objective has put us
past our error budget.
Now, let's look at how to better
secure our service traffic.
As an e-commerce
application, data security
is critical to our
enterprise and customers.
We need to ensure
our services are only
using encrypted traffic.
But recall that we noticed
earlier our shippingservice had
an open lock, revealing
that unencrypted traffic can
pass through.
Anthos lets us easily fix
this with an encryption
policy applied to
configuration, so we don't even
have to touch the service code.
Let's activate Cloud Shell
so we can make some changes
to configuration.
To be able to access our project
and make changes from the Cloud
Shell environment, we'll
need to ensure that we
have a few tools installed.
We'll be using kubectl, a clone
of our configuration repository
to synchronize our
changes, and the kubeconfig
environment for our project.
We'll source an
initialization script
into our shell environment
that takes care of all of this
for us so we're ready to go.
Once this is all done, let's
head to the config repo
clone directory.
Then let's use the
integrated editor
to quickly edit our mesh
policy so we can tighten up
our restrictions by getting
rid of permissive mode
and by requiring mutual TLS
us for all matching hosts.
After we make these
configuration changes,
we'll run nomos vet to ensure
there aren't any other issues.
Once we push our changes to the
upstream repository with git,
Anthos Config Management
will quickly detect and apply
the changes to our clusters.
We'll run a little
function helper
to go ahead and watch
for those changes here.
And that's how easy it
is to apply a policy
and have Anthos Config
Management synchronize it
across all the clusters
in your environment.
Finally, we can return to
the Connected Services view
and after enough time passes
for the desired time span,
we can visually
confirm that we only
had mTLS traffic with the green
locks for connected services.
There are plenty of examples
of security guardrails
you can set to protect
your application
environment with Anthos.
Start with the tutorial
and check out the docs
to learn more.
We've just taken a
short tour of Anthos
using a sample deployment.
This is just a taste of things
for you to try, so check out
our tutorial, launch
a sample deployment,
and explore Anthos for yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]